[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARTHUR BROOKS: One of the things that
people will learn from this course
is a very simple principle
that one of the guest speakers,
one of our guests in
this course, teaches us,
which is that happiness is love.
And what that means is that most of the
big sources of happiness in our life
that we get, they come
from our relationships,
our healthy relationships with
other people, with our family,
with our friends.
And that's critically
important because that
means if we want to put the ideas
in this course into practice
we have to do it in
conjunction with other people.
We can't wall ourselves off.
[MUSIC PLAYING]